[Music]
so welcome thank you beautiful day
beautiful Poland today we're gonna talk
or I'm gonna talk about bridging the gap
between industry and academia so that's
that's the theme but before I get there
I want to talk a little bit about the
context so my journey there so basically
I studied machine learning finished my
master then I worked for a search engine
company first as an elf engineer
developer later as the head of the
research department of the company doing
all sorts of stuff so sort of industry
experience then I realized it's it's I
like other things too so I finished my
PhD which was again computer science and
NLP what came out of there is also some
software which some of you may know like
Jenson so I maintain create it and we
maintain a few open source packages so
some of you may know me through through
the open source work which is fun too we
like that stuff but primarily after
finishing the PhD I started a company
called rare technologies where we build
systems machine learning back-end
systems so some sort of analytics
recommendation engine search engines all
sorts of stuff across all sorts of
industries so you will recognize some
household names in there so we have lots
of clients and it's very exciting
interesting work that's not the thing of
this talk so let me just move ahead
basically what we do is this
intersection between engineering and
research that's kind of our theme you
like doing that a lot of it is some of
it is primary research a lot of it is
Applied Research and we collaborate with
universities we realize we have this
large overlap between research and say
with the academic world and then with
the industry world so we launched
incubator which I will talk about quite
a bit today as a sort of bridge between
these two worlds and how that worked for
us um so that's another thing we do and
yeah in my in my spare time
I tried to have a bit of life doesn't
happen often so since 2009 we've been
living in East Asia
our last pace was in South Korea a
little island of Koreans here these
pictures actually from Thailand so um
yeah we tried to have fun when it rains
it really rains so you can see the
flooded streets and and the zoo was
flooded as well and our neighborhood had
an alligator in their backyard in the
morning because all the animals is kids
stuff like that one mentioning this is
that's sort of my theme going into it I
wear a lot of hats with research and we
do the business owner and we have open
source and as this little life component
so that's that's kind of where I am and
when I see the friction or the issues
that everybody knows that that does a
gap between industry and academia it's a
big theme lots lots of monies being
spent on how to solve it millions from
EU funds and so on so it's a hard
problem so this is just my little note
my little observations all of it
obviously will be my my opinion and I
identified two main friction points that
I would like to talk about today so the
the first of them is about risk that's a
big thing in business that people
sometimes don't recognize in academia
businesses if they could choose they
would stay the same forever they
wouldn't change they don't want any
novelty the processes are there
everything should be repeatable and
stable that's the goal the fact that
they don't do it is because they can't
because of competition but that's what
they would like they hate risk so that's
something to to keep in mind and in
academia it's kind of the opposite and
that creates the friction you want to be
novel creative and innovative so let me
give you one example of the collision so
in research researchers want to build
end-to-end systems and complex systems
and kind of hide the complexity and just
get to some good number at the end so
there's an example from some paper it
doesn't really matter what that is what
I want to highlight is that the previous
best score was ninety two point three
and
they got 93.2 and that's so that's a big
deal that's what researchers kind of
like and everything how it gets there
it's this kind of black box ideally
which is exactly what the businesses
don't want having a magic box in the
middle of of your system if that's the
nightmare for businesses it's the
unmanaged risk and this sort of chasing
of state-of-the-art that's the sort of
there is a common theme and there are a
lot of issues that come out of it and
I'm gonna be mentioning some of them
basically what we often find out because
we see all these papers coming in and we
want to see which ones actually makes
sense because it all sounds amazing and
it's all revolutionary but when we
actually look inside we find there are
issues with the implementation and all
sorts of details so it's unreproducible
a lot of it I'm kind of sad to say it's
a little cynical but when I see a paper
and I see another so the result I'm kind
of oh no not again I've been punched one
too many times so I built this defensive
reflex and I'm kind of not very excited
by so the result what I like to see is
is a paper that says we found a hack
that's for me that's the idea of things
so somebody actually looked into the
problem they understood the structure
and they found a shortcut so that's the
kind of papers that are actually
practically useful that excite me and
that are can be applied to business and
that's that's what actually works as
opposed to say you know running a great
search on two billion parameters that's
it's kind of great it gets you a bit
better results but and if you're Google
obviously it may every every percent
counts but most business is nobody will
shout at you if you're two percent worse
they will shout that you if you don't
understand the problem or if you can't
explain what's happening there's a on
the right that's kind of continuing the
theme that there were some seminal
papers in reinforcement learning and
when open AI the initiative looked into
them six of them actually had some flaws
and some flaws were serious enough that
the Sultan numbers were actually wrong
and this this happens a lot I I gave
this a name because we see this over and
over we will implement a lot of paper
some of it open-source some of it is
just for clients oh so you wouldn't know
that we did it but we do it a lot and
this happens so often that I gave it a
name I call it the mummy effect and it
doesn't only happen to let's say junior
researchers this unreproducible et when
we implemented the paragraph tech
thirsted doc - like some of you may know
again that paper was unreproducible and
that was Google brain so this was a
large company but still can reproduce
this is more recent I blacked out the
names and the context because the jury's
still out
it's possible we did something stupid
but this is an email that we sent to
some Facebook researchers we're trying
to implement that paper compare it see
how it works and we couldn't so the
mummy effect is it looks great but the
moment you touch it it crumbles to dust
like an Egyptian mummy so I call it the
mommy effect so and this is for me a
source of a lot of frustration and
before I get to tips so building the
bridges what can we do one more little
note another thing that's frustrating
for me personally is actually hiding all
the complexity behind some final metric
like final final number aggregate
numbers because more often than not
something is going wrong in the pipeline
and people don't even know there were
some good talks yesterday about this
interpretability and so on so I'm not
gonna go too deep but I just give you
two examples here these are real-world
examples so maybe some of you can spot
the error here word to vac is a specific
model it's to be trained on sentences
and each sentence is a is a list of
tokens if I can show but you see the
sentences actually uh each sentence is a
string rather than a list of tokens and
in Python this will work because you can
iterate over a string but it won't give
you tokens it will give you the
individual characters so this is an
error that happens often and people just
run the PI planet they don't even notice
they're doing nonsense and complete
rubbish but it kind of works but they
never look inside and they get some
numbers that's a good case because the
numbers will be lower so try not to
think what's going wrong and maybe go
back later but in some cases like on the
the on your left on your right building
some named entity recognizer and again
this this researcher just shuffled
everything so it was just garbled data
and through some multiple errors that
they made they actually reached 100%
results so the results were great so
they never actually looked what's wrong
but it was garbage all the way through
so this happens a lot not just for two
juniors but it happens to everybody
unfortunately I've been around long
enough that I know this does so what's
what can be done here just I guess pay
attention but what we always think
courage for example our interns and
people in the incubator is start simple
this may sound trivial but just put just
sprinkle the pipeline that you're
running with some logs it's really
simple you don't need to learn framework
don't in unit tests are nice but it's
it's unrealistic in academia just double
the work you you write the code and you
write the test but you don't know what
will end up so then you end up doing it
in two places at once
not gonna happen but this is something
else I'm talking about just maybe
replacing the comments you have just put
it in a walk and be concrete in the log
so show a few examples of what data
flows like big three of them I think I
have an example here so it's super
simple you just you build a dictionary
so instead of saying I built a
dictionary you just say it has this many
items inside and you show three of them
maybe and it sounds kind of trivial it
kind of is but this is another real
example that in one of the projects the
system was accepting text tokens but
instead it was getting some binary data
so like images or compressed files and
nobody noticed as usual but when you
actually looked at the tokens you saw
it's garbage and then you could go back
so humans are still the best anomaly
detection engine so just give them the
the input just to eyeball the results
and see maybe that something's wrong
even if a unit test couldn't catch it
like nothing's wrong with it it's still
text who cares if we're to I guess you
know
50 a vocabulary of 50 because it's
characters instead of 50,000 that's fine
but a human will immediately catch that
so really simple start simple and this
will already do a lot of good industry
will thank you for just doing this
really simple thing second thing is also
simple not as simple but still fairly
straightforward interactive demos think
there are also some some great talks
about that yesterday when you put
something in front of people they give
you feedback so they it will see all
more ice ice make all problems shallow
it's like parallel to the open source
more ice make all Box shallow and people
will show you where it doesn't work and
it will also drive you towards trying to
understand what's wrong because if you
get a bad result it will naturally like
not you towards why did it happen which
is what's missing in in the papers in
the analysis so this is a great way to
do it
how do we do it again to be concrete
little web demos so it's probably too
small for you to see but it's not very
important just some fields you click a
button and something appears that's
enough for a lot of people can be a lot
of fun it they can show you the errors
something's wrong something stupid and
you will learn something about your
whatever you created the system and
release reference implementations that's
the one on the on the right that's like
a well studied domain of finding similar
vectors in high dimensional spaces and
it's been studied for decades so I
thought if you look on that little
rainbow and and the butterfly that's
what I expected that I will find it out
of all of this research there's some
some useful stuff that I can try maybe
compare and then what's what's next to
it is what's the reality what was the
reality in 2015 when I did this
comparison of of the various approaches
and their implementations and there was
just like one library that actually
worked one and a half the other one just
failed with if you gave it too much data
so that's really sad um the second
friction point so that was sort of
managing risk
so the problem with quality okay you
look at something and you cannot trust
that it's actually correct that's very
upsetting because then the business has
to sort of do the research do the
evaluation and then the implementation
practically everything and I just too
much work it's not great
so that was managing with the second
part is ownership and that's little to
be fair there's little that academia can
do here this is more on the industry
here you see some motivating slides that
a very tongue-in-cheek very inflammatory
I would say basically people complain
that they don't understand why some
research happened what to make out of it
why is it so I'm intelligible and
strange and the source of that is of
course publish or perish I don't know
how many people come out of academia
familiar with that but basically the
goal is what you have to do as a
academician is to publish and get
citations that's how you advance in your
career which results in a huge amount of
papers that nobody reads I can see some
statistics there it's just it's it's
right on remote and also it's it
promotes this sort of little incremental
steps because you get more publications
if you publish each step of the way
rather than doing it properly so again
we're back to the quality is related to
that as well so it's just too much stuff
nobody can really follow what's going on
an archive anymore it's just stressful
annoying and most of it is crap anyway
so that's that's tricky what they say is
that is that every great library is
built on the ashes of somebody's
academic career so that's you see Travis
there some truth to that I think it's
changing a little like the tools are
getting more recognition at least by if
you measure impact by how people use it
what you see that graph on the on the
right is is the citations of jensine so
that's the little library it's not
rocket science but it still got like 700
citations be reviewed over the years so
it does help a little bit but obviously
there's not
much that people in academia can do the
only thing that really can be done is to
better explain the results to put them
in in context spend some time on
motivation why am i doing this and if
the publication's don't actually support
this you only have four six pages in
some Cherno then do a little bit of post
on the side we differently find some
other modalities of how to present it
again like the demos or publish some
blog post or a notebook to Paterno
Buchan and so on again this was
beautifully covered by I think Catherine
yesterday so I'm not gonna
I want to speed it up a little because I
have stuff I want to show you at the end
and again getting the problem right and
getting the context is more important to
almost everyone than the soten number
you get at the end if you do the error
analysis and you provide some insight
although why this should work it also
dries for the research because they can
build on that rather than just here's a
number it's better than the other number
I win how we do it we try to do this
stuff of taking various papers and just
comparing what works and what doesn't
I'm picking up the pieces and there was
a talk about how we're in the middle of
a revolution yes we are there's a lot of
corpses around sort of so we have to
pick up the pieces see what works and
what's what was just just just just the
mummy effect so and a lot of our
students in the incubator are involved
with this and I think it's beneficial to
them it's beneficial to academia it's
beneficial to industry so it's like a
win all around but primarily what what
can happen here is must come from the
industry side because the incentive
really is to publish that's how you
advance the academic career and there's
little that people in academia can can
do about that so what can happen from
the industries can sponsor we can teach
the students or the prospective
researchers the skills that we think are
liking that that bring this anxiety from
low quality results and just abandoning
the the research after it's published so
it's it's risk for the do I pick it up
nobody's touched it for years and so on
so there's some continuity
sponsoring hackathons meetups
conferences the standard stuff
open-source so again we're trying to do
all of that coming back to our incubator
it's really working well I would say
this is probably the main we only
launched incubator in 2016 so two years
ago and I think it's been great the
students love it they really we have
more than 20 graduates now from the
incubator what they do is they
collaborate on projects we we help them
we teach them the tools such as how to
share how to do organize tasks use SSH
to use our servers and the service we
provide for them in whatever Google
engine and other services so sort of
practical skills but also how to present
their results do these little demos and
see that it's not really difficult to
add a little log line here and there and
that it really helps they see that the
research that they did is better they
can trust it they're more proud of it so
it's great for them it's great for us
selfishly because three three of the
graduates we actually hired they work
for us so it's a sort of HR pipeline to
be honest and I think it's also great
for the academia because again this lot
of these people go back and cross
pollinate and and share knowledge with
their teams
yeah and we're sponsoring some
conferences and lots of other stuff
going on a little note on the
competitions this on the face of it it
looks like a great thing it's combines
the industry and and the academia as
well work on practical problems but you
apply your machine learning skills I
listed a few things that are not so
great because it turns out that a lot of
the winners it's basically about
fighting the rules you have to find the
little where it leaks where there's some
leakage in the data and that's how you
win these competitions and I think the
real heroes here are the people who
actually do the tasks who prepare the
data and define the rules because that's
a lot of work it's the most work
it's also super useful to have these
datasets but they're at a disadvantage
because they're against them is a huge
horde of very smart people who will try
to find faults in in what they did so as
little chance they can do it properly
but their work is I think amazing
it doesn't really teach the skills that
I mentioned with the collaboration and
interpretability and how to present and
so on so for us this is not the critical
it's great for what it does but it's not
the solution to what I'm talking about
the gap between the academia and the
industry and that's on the right side is
the same thing in a more diplomatic way
by Netflix so they had this price nine
years ago where they gave 1 million
dollars to two people who get the best
score in something and here you can see
when they later evaluated what actually
happened they actually didn't implement
the winning solution just for the same
reasons that I was talking about it it
was too complex too brittle so it wasn't
worth actually putting it into
production so from the business
perspective yeah they got the highest
number they got the soldier but yeah
that's it's not what businesses really
need most of the time this one is a
little tricky so I probably start with
the image so how to articulate it so
there was a discussion about language
identification if you don't know that
you have a piece of text and you want to
determine what language it's in so we're
discussing some tools which are good
which are the head and when and then
this tweet appeared that really made my
blood boil
that it's a solved problem because
that's so untrue and it shows a sort of
lack of understanding of the context
because it's not solved in and it's soft
in the sense that if you have 20
languages and you're choosing one of
them then it's that's kind of okay but
what happens in reality you don't have
20 languages it's possible that the text
is in some unknown language it's
possible that it's in multiple languages
happens all the time the various other
axes like do we need confidence with the
prediction is it maybe short text do we
also want to segment the text according
to the language blocks
so there's a lot of stuff that it's not
really solved and the point is that this
sort of definition of what is still
worth we're just chasing the numbers on
a problem that nobody cares about versus
when we should move to to a different
formulation I call that the problem
overfit that happens in research
probably if you come from engineering
you don't know what I'm talking about
but it can happen that in in in research
you you start building a complex
solution and chasing these numbers but
you get lost in the symbolic logic and
you detach yourself from reality so you
need this input this steering from-from
feedback of what is worth doing so
that's and this is where industry is
super important that's one of the main
advantages they have the subject matter
expertise so they know they can say
something that the research cannot do
like we don't really care about this
error it makes no difference so it
doesn't matter if you get 50 or 60
percent it's relevant we care about this
part of the data or these types of
errors and this type of steering is
absolutely critical and that's something
that the industry doesn't realize they
have this power like they already have
this knowledge of what's actually useful
the utility and difficulty of what we
should go one well-articulated business
problem can launch entire research
disciplines can happen so it's really
important for industry to provide this
feedback and guidance on what is
important how can that happen joint
projects basically well two ways one is
joint projects which we also tried it
didn't really work that great for us but
there's a small sample so I don't want
to extrapolate from that and another
thing is companies are starting their
own research departments more and more
before it was just a huge companies that
have these research labs obviously but
they're millions of other companies
around the world who don't have research
departments but more and more go this
way exactly for the same reason they can
define the problem they can and then
that gauge maybe chase the soda changed
chase the numbers and but the numbers
are meaningful to them it's not just
self-serving optimization
how am i doing on time I want to show
you so and this stuff that big companies
can do we're not a big company so I'm
kinda I'll be brief here but I think
they're doing a great job I think what
should be happening is that they should
lobby for the incentives to change so
that the academic careers are not
evaluated just on publications in some
arcane publishing systems falsified sort
of weird things but they also appreciate
the tools the repeatability and the
quality and there's less pressure on
publish or perish and that can happen
through the company lobbying and also
what they're doing is reducing the
dependency of this academic carrier
they're opening other options you can go
and do great research at quite a few
companies now big companies so you're
not that limited you have a lot of
freedom there and you can do your thing
and no longer matter so much that you
publish a lot of little incremental
weird papers all the time so that's my
sense is a long discussion or we skip
that and they're also putting their
brand name behind some open source and
some projects that are beneficial
sharing infrastructure software cross
pollinating with research across
companies publishing what they find in
the industry and so on this is the final
slide I was wondering whether to include
it because it's a little fuzzy it's a
bit like in the Monty Python the comedy
group behind Python the language where
they have in the meaning of life they
give this advice of don't eat too much
fat and walk a little exercise a little
read a good book be nice to people so it
feels a little underwhelming but I find
this is really important also you can
get all sorts of fights between industry
and academia versus legal and so on
everybody makes fun of the other side
people live in ivory towers and do stuff
that's not interesting and
marketing and sales they get a lot of
leg but because I wore a lot of these
hats
well I wore all of these and quite a few
more it's I can tell you that
everybody's trying as hard as they can
so maybe the it's hard for different
reasons but it's showing respect this is
a great way also to build the bridges
because everybody's really doing a hard
job none of these things are easy or
easier than the others in any
fundamental way great that's just a
summary let me skip that I want to get
to this one so if you want the summary
the slides will be probably online so
just it's we already talked about what I
want to show you today I want to
announce a new open source library what
we're releasing today you're the first
people to hear about it we call it
bounder so what is bounder I think
everybody knows counter that's that's a
new relatively new built-in tool in the
standard library of Python well you can
count the frequencies of things that
happen so you give it some objects and
it counts how many times did each object
appear it's fairly well optimized and
this is a task that it's useful across
the spectrum it's when you're analyzing
logs when you're building your your
dictionaries for your machine learning
models and all sorts of other places it
crops up it's a pretty fundamental task
of computer science now the thing with
counter is it it actually uses a lot of
memories so it's it's good at what it
does but it's too generic and we can do
better if we optimize a little what I
mean is for example in collocations
which is one of the tasks in natural
language processing you want to detect
sort of multiple tokens like phrases
that should be treated as a single unit
because you don't want to split your
company name in two maybe three words it
should count as a single unit so and you
want to do this automatically you want
to detect which which phrases are these
collocations that you wanna treat as a
single unit and in order to do that
automatically there are several
techniques but what they do is they they
need how many times does the phrase
appear as a whole where
how many times do the Constituent tokens
let's say appear in it and I just some
math and says yes no it's a collocation
or not that's not interesting but you
need these counts so that's that's the
connection okay and if you want to do
this for four large corpora because
that's where you want to find these
collocation so you have a lot of these
counts and the statistics are reliable
you find that things like counter take
too much memory okay you on the
Wikipedia I have some numbers here
they're like one
what is it almost two billion diagrams
so two tokens next to each other and it
takes a lot of memory because there's a
lot of overhead in Python with with the
object so that's like an extra I forgot
what 24 bytes for Strings extra I don't
know 16 bytes for integers and so on and
we can actually do better by using
approximations by using a smarter
algorithm and that's exactly what
counter does so that's I'm finally
coming to what counter is it's just like
counter but you can get the counts in
bounded memory you say you I have one
gigabyte and I can get the counts in
just one gigabyte instead of 31 with
what the counter would need it's it's
optimized library in C so it's actually
faster than the Python dict it's faster
than counter yet what it does and that's
a little example of how you would use it
you use it like counter but you say the
size megabytes equals 2024 you can see
there you say I only want to use one
gigabyte of memory and in that to do all
the counting and then it acts as a
counter you can get the frequencies
after you fill it with with objects it
actually has three layers of
functionality because what we found is
there multiple this is research at its
best there's actually great research on
how to do this efficiently so the
algorithms are very smart like there's
the hyper log log which lets you just
count how many distinct items are there
in the collection okay like one
operation with the cardinality of it as
a set so that's a beautiful algorithm
that we implemented it doesn't let you
do anything else like ask for the
frequencies of individual
that one just gives you how many unique
items were there and you can do this
just surprisingly and just in a few
kilobytes even for billions of items so
this is really some some well not magic
but it looks like magic going on the
second layer if you want to actually
know how many times did each individual
item appear so for example the word
Python that sort of operation you needed
different structures so here we
implemented count means catch another
beautiful algorithm that does it super
efficiently and that's how you can fit
so much information into a bounded
amount of memory so let's let's count
min sketch and then finally if you the
last the widest range of operations that
it supports is if you also need the keys
so it's a little bizarre because in the
second case you can ask how often does
each item each string appear but you
cannot enumerate which strings are in
there it just tells you if you give it
the string and it tells you how many
times but you can't say which strings
were entered into it and that's what the
third layer does it also lets you
enumerate the keys and the items just
like a counter or a dict it's the most
memory intensive so the ones above sort
of support less but are more efficient
so with the same amount of memory you
can do more data and yeah there's an
example there so how does it actually
work we did it until we tried on the
collocations just like I I mentioned and
here you see some numbers I like numbers
we're not chasing soda here it's just a
little table so the top line is the
counter so on Wikipedia or is it too
small I'll read it for you so it's 31
gigabytes of memory that it needs it
finishes it about half an hour and it
gets an f1 score of 100% because that's
the ground truth it's exact counts
coming from counter and then if you want
to get a hundred percent with with
bouncer you would if I can show it but
in the middle you see the hundred
percent there you give bounder one
gigabyte of memory and that's enough it
also gets to 100 percent accuracy so it
doesn't miss anything
100 percent precision and recall takes
about 20 minutes so it's quite a bit
faster than
so you lose nothing pretty much and then
there are few other cells where you can
see with four gigabytes of memory how it
works and interestingly because you can
say how much finger you want to give it
so you can say what if I give it just
128 megabytes so 200 times less than
than the counter well you still get 96 %
f1 accuracy so there's this trade-off
between how much memory you give it
versus how accurate the counts car and
for many tasks it's good enough like to
to have with the collocations there is
no hard line where to cut it so okay let
me just really pretty excited about this
library because it's so useful to us so
what will be happening next is we will
be replacing a lot of the functionality
that we have in our libraries like
Jensen with bounder because what happens
everywhere is you first need to scan the
vocabulary and do some filtering based
on the count and then you build models
and so on so all that will be done by
bouncer soon so we're pretty excited
about this it's already released so you
can get it from the usual places paper
some github if you want to have a look
it's open source MIT license so if you
find bucks or whatever just just let us
know and I think that's really the end
of my talk thanks for your attention
thank you read him we have time for two
short questions okay
bit of a silly question this one how did
you come up with the name bounder I was
an internal vote in our company so we're
democratic like that so now what it
means is it's like counter but nano
rebound it's like bounded counter yes
sorry okay second question my question
is does this drop in accuracy is this
drop in accuracy resolved in any special
way or is it just the does it just
depend on the data structure she used I
mean does it for example over us
underestimate big counts or
underestimate small counts is it guided
in any way or it's just you know using
appropriate probabilistic data yeah
there's actually quite a bit of
engineering behind it that I didn't go
into but these these algorithms like for
example the count means catch they have
some internal parameters like the width
of the hashes that they use and so on
and these are set automatically when you
say I want one one gigabyte to something
but there's also like a power user mode
where you can go in and do these
trade-offs manually so what sort of
accuracy there's also a mode which I
didn't talk about but you can represent
actually counts not as integers but in a
probabilistic way which is in its really
bizarre but it like one byte you can
represent a whole range of numbers up to
four billion or something like that okay
with less accuracy so you save you in 1
byte instead of 256 values you can do
four billion values so it's kind of
weird but again it's a trade-off with
accuracy so there's a lot of these
little tweaks if you're really
interested like for the power users and
it's in the documentation
can I have it just one question thanks
for a great talk I'm looking yeah I'm
here on the left you're here oh thanks
for a great duck so I'm actually a bit
of a similar situation and live on a
enter intersection of science and
business and I think that science
started to realize that you know
figuring out the better results a lot of
conferences is not the way to go so
there are more and more conferences that
are actually appreciating the work and
not only the numbers but from your
experience what's the best way of
collaboration between academia and
research is like research grants that I
have no strings attached or is it like a
joint ventures or outsourcing some work
to the universities because you know
getting better results and expecting the
the academia to provide like you know
out-of-the-box solutions for business is
not fair either because this is public
money and here's you know privately
owned company so there has to be some
sort of a collaboration going on but
what's the best option here for us I
mentioned it didn't really work yeah
great question but for us the
collaborations didn't really work mostly
because we operate at a different
frequency different pace so like direct
collaboration wasn't great but what
really works is growing the talents and
the workforce that's what I'm I guess
the happiest about this incubator it
costs our time like we're doing it it's
for free this mentorship the students
don't pay anything we just do it for
them same with the open source you can
get it for free but it costs us money
obviously an effort so like educating
the workforce on how things should be
done we think that's the best probably
return on investment that we have we
don't expect any direct you know like
you say products coming out of academia
I'm I'm a simple person I like simple
things so you saw what I recommend you
just put some blocks in there you know
so it's not completely a little sanity
check goes a long way that's that's our
expectation thank you so much thank you
ready for a talk and I feel really
honored that you have announced this
library during my data or so
thing I wanted to mention so we have
some open source stickers up here so if
you like that I'm gonna get some we can
move the stickers during the break to
non focus table over there so you can
there's a bunch of stickers over there
so we can pick them up know from from
this table so yeah
pick up Laos ready
[Applause]
you